hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Arianna
there is this video sent to us I don't
know what kind of video what's gonna be
I don't know who's gonna be dark and
serious or funny but it's called don't
stay in school I did not even finish
high school he did it and I never
attempted college I did so I said I will
mainly just watch trailers and hope to
make a living off that and so far
watching videos has been great for me
and reviewing other people's content and
college was kind of college was very
unnecessary who would have thought I
could just watch other people's
creativity and talk about it
self respect right here
Oh God I wasn't taught how to get a job
in every I can remember dissecting a
frog I wasn't taught how to pay tax but
I know loads about Shakespeare's
classics I was never taught how to vote
they devoted that time did defining
isotopes I wasn't oh I had to look after
my health but mitochondria is the
powerhouse of the cell never spent a
lesson on current events instead I
studied the old American West I was
never taught what laws there are I was
never taught what laws there are let me
repeat I was not taught the laws about
the country I live in but I know how
Henry the eighth's killed his women
divorced beheaded died divorced beheaded
survived now that's in my head instead
of financial advice I was shown the
wavelengths of different years of light
but I was never taught by human rights
apparently this 30 do you know them I
don't where the hell can we both recite
them by won't I know Neos metamorphic
and sedimentary box yet I don't know
squat about training stop - how money
works at all where does it come from how
does the thing that motivates the world
function not to budget and displace my
learnings I was too busy there
rehearsing cursive didn't one hour to
cook the way to kilowatts an affidavit
is but especially so what the
equation is P plus or minus is family to
b squared minus 4ac over 2a
that's insane absolutely insane they may
be learned back to the basic dos stage
how to recognize the most deadly mental
disorders or diseases with preventable
causes or how to buy a house with a
mortgage if I could afford it cuz
abstract maths was deemed more important
than advise the would literally save
thousands of lives
but it's cool cuz now I could tell you a
clinic over unnecessary deaths caused by
that choice was prying never bad present
day practical medicines but I was told
what the ancient Hippocratic method is
i've got a headache the pain is
ceaseless what should I take um maybe
try some leeches
let's go have mystic abusing at the back
so how to help my distressed friend with
a mental state um no mental map because
you won't have a calculator with you
every day they say it's not the kids the
parents are the problem but if you drop
the kids to parents and absorb them well
this advices obviously your cleanser but
number when you actually have a kid but
you want one I'm only flew into this
language the serious the rest of the
world speak truth you think I'm an avian
psychosis all over the political systems
of like until cities and now I don't
know what to voting on which policies
exist or how to make them change me we
should pull the Paul says Renee Tina was
expected to protect Symmetry's entity
from a system ID that never ever ever
been presented with the room take it
I'll tell everyone like
who's wasted masuren everywhere who are
educated and insist these pointless
things don't stay in school
I love that last sentence yeah
true
okay I I mean we always talk about how
we don't know about taxes and real stuff
I asked my principal if we could get
those babies like home Ecsta yeah I wish
school was morsel like when I didn't go
to college
it wasn't like I'm lazy and didn't want
to go it was because I saw that most
people have degrees most people are
broke so they tell their children get a
degree because you have to make money
because we're broke and then they end up
having so college loan debt they'll
never be able to pay up and then I would
see that a lot of successful people
didn't have degrees it comes down to you
know what you know but also how you
apply what you know and what it is you
really want to learn about and become
passionate about and I wish school gave
you more options for what you could do I
feel like that's what college should
have been is like the playground to like
see what careers you might want but it
doesn't have to be only those careers
right I got very much so stuck I had to
choose my major applying to school but I
do think it makes sense for people who
want it who knows after what they want
to do and they get connections through
internships through their school
absolutely that's when it makes sense
but for people who want to do acting or
dance or things like something
interesting like you know like me I
don't feel like you have to tell people
not to stay in school
I just wish school is different yeah I
just wish school added things to it or
allowed things to be more options rather
than no you have to learn this this and
this when it's like you don't
necessarily have to learn it it's like
what if there's something else they'd
rather learn can they get that option
instead you know rather than here's the
mandatory requirements right right I
mean I really I don't understand I don't
know anyone who had whole neck or
anything
almost practical like that or shop yeah
and have that I also feel that I think
it's sad how people think that the only
way to be successful is with a degree
and I feel most people think that yet
most people are not successful it's a
weird thing that we have or it's like oh
that degree but degrees used to mean
something
catch-22 ish what you mean some things
you do have to have a degree Oh totally
yeah if you want to be like a doctor or
low
there are some people who've made it
without a degree and you're like Oh see
you don't need one but there's some
people there's a lot of people without
degrees who also haven't done it yeah
I'm just saying I want school to be more
tailored to what the individual actually
wants to do right yeah that's are you ok
you're pushing your cheeks right yeah I
know I mean I do wish I knew more about
politics and structures you did have
long hair yeah he looked like a gold
Ramat about that what this guy was
saying was
they don't teach you about life they
don't teach you life's now I know you
know I like that line about saying like
I don't know anything about my current
day politics but I know a lot of them
like yeah they don't really teach people
an individual how to there's life style
when buying a house oh ya know what is
the first step to that yeah
financial education we should definitely
get learning how to like live as an
adult we should get well we should also
get like lifestyle advice you know it's
like that's what that's really saying
well you're saying like how you know
like that's where the parents are there
for is to teach you how to live your
life more but you know then there's it
comes down to good parenting and bad
parenting so whatever you learn can
change maybe I'll send my kid to some
one of those artsy schools where they
don't have real grades and it's like
yeah hearts and smileys that would be
great it should be a Jewish school to
make sure you do that I don't want to go
I want to do what was the point she feel
more Jewish right my name is Hebrew for
me what I was taught I heard this from a
very wealthy man he said formal
education makes you a living self
education makes you a fortune and I feel
like most people only feel educated when
they go to school or do that but really
it's what you do outside of that how you
teach yourself so we're gonna start
school is what you're saying I'm saying
life is school so we're gonna start a
school where we people pay us money and
we take the life yeah trying to make a
business out of this yeah be cool you
know you teach people how to live a good
life how to feel their feelings and
other positively psychologically you
know we're the Kratt right where the
qualify once
this let me teach you about life yeah
well anyway guys thanks for saying that
video is out if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects you can check out re on a busser
each channel a lot of fun stuff coming
soon already has a video up maybe to you
on video maybe by the time this comes
out I'll be done editing my second list
there you go there you go and you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter where if we get enough followers
product placement but normally I follow
this up with some product placement sex
joke but instead we're gonna do a shout
out Donovan Greenfield Donovan hey Ryan
reactor jinx has passed you thanks cuz
jinx is a reactor and there's this whole
controversy I don't give a [ __ ] about it
but it's people thought like oh is he
buying subscribers you know and you can
buy subscribers if they're not real
subscribers I don't care hey you should
care cuz you will waste your money and
it won't do anything for you because you
won't get views from it really impressed
that is what people bought jinks might
have been doing by this point I don't
being jinx has done that there's a lot
of room on the Internet
take the both of you I'm calm down
but Donovan said anyway I love your
channel have been watching since
February 2014 love your channel keep
doing your things thanks Donovan
Greenfield
Donovan you know Donna fresh easy Jewish
Greenfield yeah it's totally Jewish
music these are Jews just as dad is
Jewish he's not mama sent ya as mom's a
pureblood Jehovah's Witness darling I'm
sorry
Donovan Greenfield he's a Jew who smokes
a lot of weed in his field of marijuana
I'll see what I did see what I did Green
Greenfield has his field full of
marijuana
I'm trying to make you look good right
now
how how does that make me look good
you're next to me and I'm a sensation
yeah I have the record for number one
most subscribers I have passed over a
hundred thousand subscribers there's no
one out there with any more subscribers
no one only jinx